findet bald eine hashtags hochzeit statt
was geht hier ist ali und ich bin gerade
im urlaub an der nordsee schon seit ein
paar tagen und heute will ich mit ihr
lieben es einfach ein bisschen chillen
ein paar fragen beantworten und falls
gewundert was das für eine qualität ist
das ist meine große politik nicht mehr
an die ich mir bei diesem video ins
wasser gefallen es ist dafür sehr cool
zum mond ist aber ja wir gehen jetzt
erst mal entspannungs was tippen holen
und dann setzen wir uns in den strand
und machen vielleicht ein paar fragen
die ich dass keine ahnung bis gleich
der endstand
frühstücken um halb drei urlaub hat aber
eine sache noch sagen und zwar hat der
gute herr es kay an eigenen bürger
gemacht bei mcdonald's wir können jetzt
auf jeden fall ein usa-trip gewinnen
wenn ihr uns dass reporter das heißt wir
müssten auf den link und in der
beschreibung klicken einfach nur auf den
ersten sieg des burger draufklicken und
damit schon helfen weil das geht noch
bis morgen bis morgen also erstmal power
morgen und übermorgen ist dann nochmal
beuting auf facebook der welches
wahrscheinlich auch nochmal anhören
müssen sein sound kommt dass auch die
akkorde krass okay also morgen bin ich
auf jeden fall aktiv sein
wir machen gerade einen kleinen
windschutz also was ihr davon haltet
einfach blogs peterson aus den usa
und wir hatten eine gute zeit also wenn
ihr so supporten wollte was natürlich
sehr lieb wäre
einmal klicken in der beschreibung
weiter an strand
ein
man fragt sich natürlich wie hashtag
berlin anni fragt ist echt gut im haus
aber graf einem haus nein muss kein
ochsenhausen dem haus wo ich wohne ich
es einfach keinen obst in 15 gesunder
mensch hier ist gerade einen darf ich
etwa schneiden
ak doch da oder welchen anderen zwecken
der einnahmen
ich meinte findet bald eine herstellt
maut hochzeit statt
ich habe mich das okay von es ganz böse
sofort los ich wähle mich ein besten
lässt man eigentlich auf deutsch
es kam ja nee ich weiß noch nicht ob ich
den mann okay geben kann diese hochzeit
wenn die möglichkeit bestehen würde
würde die dann zusammen auswandern
ich würde sagen nein ich finde
eigentlich so schnell in deutschland
also gut gut wo nicht immer schön aber
gut auf jeden fall schon sehr stark
einzig und allein an sich schon könnte
ich mir schon vorstellen weil ich denke
immer wusste aber irgendwas große müssen
wir passieren genau an mein leben
deswegen weil es eigentlich ganz normal
das komplette tapetenwechsel und warten
möchte anderen papiere kein später
machen und vietnam
leoni aber irgendwo anders sind dann
vielleicht irgend ein schloss bauen in
thailand börse weil nicht teil 1 1 in st
hier eine sehr gute frage zum urlaub
hier seid ihr früher oder später
aufstehen also ich bin eigentlich voll
er früher stellen normalerweise stehen
acht uhr auf im bach von selbst auch
wenn ich vor wenig schlafen hatte aber
mit diesem urlaub sehen wie alles anders
ich habe zum beispiel weshalb zwei
geschlafen heute sind wir nun zwei es
raus und haben geprüft
ich war auch schon um halb elf fach
glaube ich aber ja ich werde vor der
frühaufsteher die klappe die jetzt
bisschen anders bei mir später anders ja
ich bin eher so ein langschläfer ich
muss mir immer an sechs stellen als ich
mir echt jeden morgen und wecker stellen
damit irgendwie aus der kiste komme so
ohneberg aufstehen geht gar nicht aber
was dann
demmin schlafbedarf angeht brauchst du
ein bisschen mehr
also ich später ein aber ich brauche
nicht unbedingt zu viel schlaf
er stimmt ich möchte mal acht stunden
schlafen er mag so laut ihr kommt frage
rein das sieht einfach aus wie die
scripted deshalb sollte einfach mal was
macht ihr wenn ihr die amerika reise und
das bürgerbad herr winter meint burger
battle der gute herr es ist ja beim
letzten mal wo wir eure hilfe überhaupt
haben schon die isar gesprungen in
münchen als irgendwie der fluss 8 grad
hat also hat sich die füße
aufgeschnitten hat noch gar nicht
gesehen hat sich beide füße
aufgeschnitten am flussbett und ich habe
ihm dann verbunden mit einer socke und
im tempo und dann sind wir nach hause
gefahren sagt das war sehr sehr tricky
und das mit toiletten
desinfektionsmittel auf die witzige
fürchten
babacan auf jeden fall könnt ihr euch
was überlegen wenn ihr bock habt wenn
ihr den mal richtig leiden sehen wollt
vielleicht irgendwie so american style
also irgendwie sprüht käse in die
nasenlöcher dann schreib was in die
kommentare
überlegt euch was sie wird sagen das
war's dann von uns von heute ist
vielleicht ein bisschen kürzer geworden
aber hier auf der insel eine kleine
insel hat man nicht so super internet
von daher bisher kürzer und auch
improvisations mäßig weiß nicht ob ich
mich mal dass ich auch erst in zwei
tagen wieder was kommen wird
aber dann bin ich erstmal in köln
und kann dann denke ich mal anständig
wieder produzieren ja auf jeden fall
denn das war's von heute beginne es nach
hause macht's gut